[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais menace ou la vis en elle-même est
très dangereuse a traversé pour les
piétons et j'espère que le projet
d'aménagement concernera un passage
souterrain pour les piétons ce sera
beaucoup moins dangereux pour les
enfants qui habitent de l'autre côté
oui des aménagements pour le passage là
bas
face à station mobile surtout dangereux
pour les piétons c'est qu'il faut que je
fasse très attention à la fois une
déviation
passez pas aussi qu'ils ont construite
autour il y a eu deux morts le week-end
des 16 et 17 novembre sur la nationale
10 attrapés l'encours cela porte à 18 le
nombre de tués en dix ans sur cette voie
pour la seule ville de trappes depuis
1965 pourtant le contournement de la
ville par l'autoroute a12 est prévu
permettant ainsi de transformer la
nationale 10 en un boulevard urbain
reste que deux solutions sont
concurrentes l'une inscrite au schéma
directeur d'île de france passerait en
zone urbaine par la verrière et le
mesnil
elle rencontre l'hostilité quasi unanime
des élus locaux
l'autre prenais part ceci passerait plus
au large de la ville nouvelle par le
vallon du pommeraie problème il faudrait
des classes et quelques hectomètres de
cette zone boisée au final un blocage
qui dure est contenté de casser les élus
ont sollicité un rendez vous auprès du
préfet illac redit 20 novembre
nous voulions donc dire à monsieur le
préfet qu' il ne pouvait pas être
accepté en l'état le tracé médian qui
qui est inscrit au sdrif au schéma de la
région ile-de-france qui se propose de
passer bon dans des conditions que l'on
ne connaît pas encore bien par leur
proximité du ministre denis est de plus
ou moins enterré prod plus ou moins
protégés par la verrière pour déboucher
sur l'a10 vers coignières alors
concernant la nationale 10 nous ne
voulons pas d'aménagement la question
qui est posée c'est la transformation
d'une voix qui aujourd'hui est
autoroutières dans sa configuration qui
donne à l'automobiliste l'impression
qu'il est toujours sur l'autoroute de
transformer cette voie ce statut doit
autoroutières en statue de boulevard
urbain la dde devrait rendre public dans
les six mois une étude sur les travaux à
prévoir sur la nationale 10 à trappes
reste la question du financement des
coûts un dossier qui lui non plus n'est
pas encore ficelé
[Musique]
situé dans l'essonne à quelques
kilomètres de la ville nouvelle
le cea commissariat à l'énergie atomique
de saclay est le plus grand centre de
recherche français et européens dans
cette véritable bible qui s'étend sur
plus de 2000 hectares environ 8000
personnes travaillent chaque jour et des
centaines de chercheurs bien du monde
entier mais que recherche-t-on
véritablement au cea de saclay sac
laissé la recherche fondamentale ainsi
que de la recherche appliquée mais dans
tous les domaines c'est un peu le creux
g en matière de recherche fondamentale
pour toutes les disciplines et ensuite
ce qui se fait à saclay irrigue les
autres secteurs de façon très
schématique
il ya un premier aboutissement c'est
confus confiance
comment je suis constitué l'univers et
l'histoire des étoiles les galaxies du
soleil et de la terre
c'est comprendre comment fonctionne plus
intime de la matière est entendu qu'il
ya des violations évidentes entre les
dés le 18 octobre 1945 le général de
gaulle créée par ordonnance le premier
organisme public de recherche
le cea est alors chargé de donner à la
france la maîtrise de l'atome dans des
secteurs aussi variés que la science
l'énergie l'industrie ou encore la
défense mais le premier souci du général
à l'époque et de donner avant tout à la
france son indépendance énergétique au
cirad sac mais on taquine l'atome
uniquement dans un but civil pour son
50e anniversaire les portes du site se
sont ouvertes pour la première fois sur
l'extérieur visite d'un laboratoire de
notre monde termine en touriste en et
les invitations et ce principe est
envisagé en particulier au japon pour
faire des trains à la vie nationale
mais aucun frottement et votre mandat
ici nous concerne nous faisons la
conception et la réalisation des
manceaux par conducteur donc ce que nous
avons derrière nous c'est une station
d'essai qui nous permet de tester ces
aimants supraconducteurs 2 2
mesurer leurs caractéristiques
électriques et magnétiques le but de ces
travaux sera la construction du plus
grand accélérateur mondial de lâcher au
cern qui devrait permettre de progresser
encore d'un conte d'un connaissance des
consultants intime de la matière c'est à
dire ce que l'on recherche et le besoin
de 602 croit le besoin de x est la
particule la plus fondamentale que l'on
espère plus actuellement
plus performant que le rayon x la
lumière ou les électrons le nôtre on
sait depuis une quarantaine d'années
révélé comme une source indispensable
aux chercheurs pour scruter la matière
pour les produire et mener à bien leurs
expériences ces derniers disposent sur
place de véritables réacteurs nucléaires
ici nous sommes une source de neutrons
produit des nôtres en des faisceaux de
neutrons pour les physiciens
uniquement pour la recherche
fondamentale
exactement usine à l'autre source de
neutrons la plus moderne d'europe les
chercheurs viennent parfois de très loin
pour profiter des neutrons produit à
saclay installés autour du coeur du
réacteur
chacun dans leur coin les analyses
calcul mesure excusez moi que vous
faites là vu de mes sûr avec diffusion
inélastique teneur trop des vibrations
dans des cristaux des supraconducteurs c
le fameux
c'est pas conducteur ait étreint par
yeom vivre aux oxydes mais bien sûr que
suis-je bête pourquoi n'y est pas pensé
plus tôt
si la réalité des travaux menés dans les
laboratoires du cea saclay nous échappe
quelque peu il faut être conscient que
les recherches les expériences menées
depuis 50 ans grâce au nucléaire par les
équipes du commissariat à l'énergie
atomique profite à tous les domaines
biologie robotique climatologie
informatique et j'en passe si l'atome
peut être destructeur il est aussi
source de création dans ce monde
parallèle aux allures de nautilus c'est
l'avenir du futur que l'on prépare
[Musique]